>> CONGRESS NEEDS TO COME IN TO
SESSION TOMORROW.
IF ALL OF OUR SCIENTIFIC
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO GET THIS
VACCINE TESTED, DONE, DESIGN,
AND READY TO GO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE, SO WE CAN GO BACK TO
BEING A FREE COUNTRY, IF THAT’S
THE METRIC, THEN WE ALL NEED TO
KNOW THAT NOW.
SO LAST NIGHT I CALLED ON
CONGRESS TO COME BACK.
COME BACK TO D.C.
DO YOUR JOB.
BE PART OF THE WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH.
IF THAT MEANS ALLOCATING MORE
MONEY TO GET A VACCINE ON THE
MARKET FASTER, THEN SO BE IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THIS IS A
WAR.
SO LET’S ACT LIKE IT.
NOW AS I SAID EARLIER, CONGRESS
WAS IN SESSION ALMOST
CONTINUOUSLY THROUGHOUT
WORLD WAR II.
AND DURING MOST OF THE DISEASE
PANDEMIC IN RECENT HISTORY.
OF COURSE THE 1918 SPANISH FLU
WERE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS STATE
ON CAPITOL HILL TO PASS VITAL
PUBLIC HEALTH LEGISLATION.
THEY PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
LITERALLY.
THAT OUTBREAK ACTUALLY KILLED A
HANDFUL OF LAWMAKERS.
JOINING ME NOW IS SENATOR AND
DOCTOR, AN OLD FRIEND,
SENATOR JOHN BARRASSO.
A WYOMING.
AND CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
SENATOR, YOU’RE A PHYSICIAN.
EVERY TIME SOMEONE HAS AN ACHE
AND PAIN ON CAPITOL HILL, THEY
CALL YOU UP HERE WHY NOT HAVE
CONGRESS COME BACK TO ASK SOME
OF THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
METRICS THAT WE ARE USING COME
OF THE STUDIES WERE USING.
GIVEN WHAT’S AT STAKE FOR OUR
COUNTRY IF THIS SHUTDOWN GOES ON
MUCH PASSED APRIL 30.
>> THE PRESIDENT CALLED ME THIS
MORNING AND HIS NUMBER ONE
CONCERN OF COURSE IS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND WE HAVE JUST PASSED THE
LARGEST BILL IN THE HISTORY OF
THE UNITED STATES THAT THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED, THE CARES ACT,
AIMED AT PROVIDING OUR MEDICAL
CAREGIVERS EVERY THING THEY NEED
TO, TAKING CARE OF OUR FAMILIES,
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES, AND OUR
HARD-HIT SECTORS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT IS IMPLEMENT IMPROPERLY.
THE LAST THING WE NEED TO DO IS
TO PASS ANOTHER BILL ON TOP OF
THAT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE AND I’M
VISITING WITH HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATORS AND DOCTORS IN
WYOMING, SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS,
THIS IS WHERE WE I NEED TO BE
MAKING SURE THAT THIS TOO
TRILLION DOLLAR BILL IS
IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN NUNES,
YOU HEARD THAT DURING THE
PANDEMIC OF 1918 DURING
WORLD WAR II, CONGRESS WAS
IN SESSION ALMOST CONTINUOUSLY.
VERY FEW BREAKS.
I KNOW EVERYBODY WANTS TO GET
HOME WITH THEIR FAMILIES BUT I
MEAN, WE HAVE AMERICANS WHO ARE
FREAKING OUT EITHER FROM GETTING
THIS DISEASE, VIRUS, OR FROM
LOSING HER JOB AND NEVER GETTING
IT BACK.
AND THEY’RE NOT SURE WHAT THE
ULTIMATE SUCCESS RATE WILL LOOK
LIKE AND THEY ARE LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS.
THOUGHTS.
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK IT’S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET BACK AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
BUT AS SENATOR BURR ALSO SAID,
RIGHT NOW WE STILL HAVE AN ISSUE
THAT MOST PEOPLE AND
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES DON’T
UNDERSTAND THAT EMPLOYERS GET
TWO WEEKS OF SICK LEAVE, STILL A
OF BUSINESSES STILL HAVE NOT
IMPLEMENTED THAT.
THAT’S A WAY TO KEEP TWO WEEKS
OF EVERYBODY STILL WORKING.
THAT’S PART OF THE MONEY THAT WE
DID IN PHASE ONE.
PEOPLE DON’T UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND IN PHASE TWO THAT WE JUST
PASSED LAST WEEK, TWO AND A HALF
TIMES THE PAYROLL THAT
BUSINESSES CAN GO ON BORROW AND
GET THAT MONEY ULTIMATELY TURNED
INTO A GRANT.
SO I AM DEALING WITH ALL OF
THESE ISSUES TRYING TO GET THIS
MESSAGE OUT.
I THINK QUITE FRANKLY ALL OF
AMERICA’S POLITICIANS AND THE
MEDIA COULD STOP LOOKING AT THE
DEATH COUNTERS AND I THINK
YOU’RE VERY RIGHT.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE DEATH
RATE.
SEE WHAT THAT’S GOING TO DO.
WE NEED A LOT MORE DATA.
LET’S STOP LOOKING AT THE DEATH
COUNTERS AND LET’S TALK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN KEEP AS MANY PEOPLE
EMPLOYED AS POSSIBLE.
THAT’S THE KEY RIGHT NOW, LAURA,
BECAUSE IF YOU DON’T, WE SAID
EARLIER IS CORRECT.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE STAYING AT
HOME, NOT TAKING CARE OF
THEMSELVES, YOU WILL END UP WITH
A HELL OF A LOT MORE PEOPLE
DYING BY OTHER CAUSES THEN YOU
WILL BUY THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> Laura: SENATOR BURR ALSO,
THERE WAS A MOMENT AT
YESTERDAY’S PRESS BRIEFING THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAD THEIR
EYEBROWS RAISED AFTER WATCHING
IT.
I WANT TO PLAY IT FOR YOU.
WATCH.
>> THE ROAD MAP ALSO TALKS ABOUT
DOING GPS FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING,
MAYBE FOLLOWING PEOPLE’S PHONES
AND HOTELS FOR ISOLATION FOR
PEOPLE.
GIVING THEM FREE HOTEL ROOMS.
ARE THOSE IDEAS THAT YOU’RE
LOOKING OUT?
SPEAK OF THE GPS IS A VERY
SEVERE IDEA.
I’VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT IT.
GPS, SIREN GOES OFF YOU GO CLOSE
TO SOMEBODY?
THAT’S PRETTY SEVERE.
I JUST RECEIVED, I RECEIVED IT A
LITTLE WHILE AGO.
>> Laura: TALKING ABOUT THE
ROAD MAP TO RECOVERY.
THE FORMER COMMISSIONER WROTE.
PART OF THAT ROAD MAP INCLUDED A
POSSIBLE GPS TRACKING,
SENATOR BARRASSO, OF INDIVIDUALS
UNDER THE STATE LOCKDOWN ORDERS.
DO YOU SUPPORT IN ANY WAY THE
ADMINISTRATION EVER GOING EVEN
CLOSE TO THAT.
THE PRESIDENT CERTAINLY DIDN’T
SEEM TO BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING WE WOULD REQUIRE.
>> I AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT,
NO I DON’T THINK WE OUGHT TO GO
THAT WAY.
THIS CORONAVIRUS HAS IMPACTED
THE LIVES AND THE LIVELIHOODS OF
SO MANY.
IT SHOULD NOT IMPEDE ON OUR
LIBERTIES AS AMERICAN CITIZENS.
I WOULD BE OPPOSED TO WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT DOING
THAT IN EUROPE.
THAT’S BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT.
I CAN IMAGINE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WOULD BE WILLING TO DO
THAT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN
DO AND YOU HAVE BEEN REALLY GOOD
AT POINTING THIS OUT IN TERMS OF
JUMPING AHEAD OF THIS, DOING THE
KIND OF RESEARCH THAT’S BEING
DONE WITH ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
MEDICINES.
THERE ARE FIVE DIFFERENT
MEDICINES BEING TESTED, NOT THE
OLD SCIENTIFIC DOUBLE-BLIND GIVE
THEM A SUGAR PILL APPROACH.
SEE WHAT’S WORKING IN THE FIELD,
EVEN IF IT ISN’T A CURE.
THESE ARE MEDICINES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND WE KNOW THEY ARE
SAFE BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TAKING THEM FOR YEARS AND EVEN
IF THEY DON’T GIVE A FULL CURE,
IF THEY CAN LESSEN THE SYMPTOMS
OR GET SOMEBODY BACK AND HEALTHY
SOONER, I THINK THAT’S GOING TO
BE THE BREAKTHROUGH MUCH SOONER
THAN A VACCINE WHICH EVEN THE
QUICKEST VACCINE CAN TAKE TWO OR
THREE YEARS TO DEVELOP.
>> Laura: BACK TO THE GOTTLIEB
ROAD MAP.
DR. FAUCI, THEY ARE TIGHT AND
THEY RELY ON GOTTLIEB’S ADVICE.
HE SAID WE CAN’T GO BACK TO A
NORMAL LIFE UNTIL WE HAVE A
VACCINE.
THAT’S BASICALLY WHAT HE SAID.
THAT WOULD BE NOT GOING BACK TO
NORMAL LIFE, CONGRESSMAN NUNES,
FOR 12 MONTHS.
WHICH IF PARENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE HEARING THAT, AND
WORKERS, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SHOWING UP IN WASHINGTON, EVEN
IF YOU ALL AREN’T HERE.
THEY’RE GOING TO BE COMING TO
WASHINGTON TO SEND YOU A
MESSAGE.
>> THAT’S NOT GOING TO WORK.
THE SCHOOLS WERE CANCELED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WAY
OVERKILL.
IT’S POSSIBLE KIDS COULD’VE WENT
BACK TO SCHOOL IN TWO WEEKS TO
FOUR WEEKS BUT THEY JUST
CANCELED THE REST OF THE
SCHOOLS.
SOBEL, I’M OPTIMISTIC HERE.
I THINK THAT THE DRUGS THAT ARE
ON THE MARKET NOW, LOOK HOW
QUICK WE WERE ABLE TO GET THIS
APPROVED, THIS NEW MALARIA DRUG.
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
EVERY NIGHT.
THERE’S A LOT OF OPTIMISM HERE
THAT WE HAVE IN SOME OF THESE
DRUGS THAT ARE COMING ONLINE.
THE VACCINES ARE GOING TO TAKE A
WHILE BUT LOOK, WE HAVE THIS
BILL THAT WE JUST PASSED LAST
WEEK, $2.2 TRILLION WORTH, WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON KEEPING PEOPLE
EMPLOYED.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
IF WE DON’T START TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK IN THIS COUNTRY
OVER THE NEXT WEEK TO TWO WEEKS,
I DON’T BELIEVE WE CAN WAIT
UNTIL THE END OF APRIL.
I JUST DON’T KNOW OF ANY ECONOMY
THAT’S EVER SURVIVED OR YOU
UNPLUG THE ENTIRE ECONOMY AND
EXPECT THINGS TO GO BACK AND BE
NORMAL.
SO THE MORE TESTS THAT ARE OUT
THERE, THE MORE PEOPLE GETTING
TESTING, LET’S LEARN ABOUT THE
TREATMENTS.
LET’S GET GOOD DATA AS TO WHO IS
BEING IMPACTED AND LET’S FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET BACK TO WORK.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.